Eric is with us in Houston Texas I Eric
how are you hi doing Dave merry
Christmas to you you too sir
how can I help yes sir I'm 25 years old
and I recently just started listening to
your show and watching all the our
YouTube videos and I just want to ask
you how is it possible that I could find
whoever is it is our old app to another
party a couple of banks and like right
now I'm paying school of their
graduation 50% of my my wages from every
check other than them how can I find out
who they are who do you think you owe
why do you think you have debt what I
believe are a couple of banks because in
our ginger I had a couple of checking
accounts and a fusion with overdraft and
I was paying on them in and out and I I
lost work and I couldn't pay them
anymore
yes you have to give to potential
overdraft debts out there and what other
debts much you have oh I believe I had
took out
I got an account with with the cons the
electronic store and I believe I may
still owe them some money too and you
know this was when I got when I
graduated high school I was having stuff
sent to me by mail get credit here you
created there and you know I did not
know anything about yeah just you know
the potential is that is that electronic
stores are open I believe them they may
they may still be open but up I went
into there recently and they said they
send my account to death Thursday I
guess they might have bought in but the
account and I came find out who who they
are
okay what about the oil banks are they
still open I believe they one of them is
both Fargo and the other one is our I
believe it could be it could be hot I
can't remember okay well there's there's
no there's no master list of all debts
owed
we're I mean you just kinda have to
start doing some investigative research
and just what you did you go into the
electronics store and try to find out
who it is the only chance you've got to
finding some of those folks is pull a
copy of your credit bureau report have
you done that no sir I haven't
I'm not sure which which place or which
credit bureau or I could go to that's um
I would just go to another
freecreditreport.com and you can get a
free credit report there once a year and
just pull a copy of your credit bureau
report it'll probably have a lot of them
on there and it will give you a point of
contact for almost any of them and then
you can go what you'll need to do then
when you find them is they're going it
for instance that electronic store
that's things what that's a five six
seven years old right yes sir yeah okay
and so what what they're going to have
done is they're going to take the
original balance and they're going to
have added in interest to it plus a lot
of collections fees and maybe even some
other gotcha stuff and so what you need
to do is try to figure out what the
original amount that you borrowed was
and they will settle for that or laughs
okay
so let's pretend you have any idea what
you might have borrowed how much I
believe you was right around the
ballpark of maybe two thousand dollars
okay let's pretend you open up that
account and call them and they say oh
with fees it's now eight thousand
dollars oh well which is probably what
you're going to hear okay then you just
tell them the truth I don't have eight
thousand dollars I do have two if you've
got two I do have two and I can settle
that with you if you want to settle the
debt for two thousand I can send you
that money today okay but do not give
them the full amount because they've got
a lot of extra collections fees and
things at it and they're some of them
are even illegal okay so it's going to
be jacked way up every time you open up
one of these things even the ones with
the bank and then what you want to do is
say I want to settle it in full and
you're going to have to negotiate with
them and argue with them because they're
going to go back and forth back and
forth
I got two all I gots to and when you if
you want to I'll give you two but I'm
not giving you two unless it settles the
whole debt I want this off my record
okay and you post it that way then what
you've got to do is two things you
remember when you're settling the debt
once you've gotten it that far okay once
they've agreed to it you do not have a
deal unless you have it in writing so
they need to send you an email or a
letter or something saying all right we
have the eight thousand dollar debt with
khan's electronics and we will settle it
for two okay okay and they need to set
give you that with an account number on
it or whatever and you keep that email
print out a hard copy of it in case your
computer goes bad keep it in a file with
a cap with a copy of the with the jack
that you send to them
okay okay for the rest of your life
because there this is going to come up
again and there some collector is going
to call you and go hey you remember that
electronic thing no I settled that know
you still owe $4,000 and they're going
to lie and try to collect more later and
you're going to have to have proof that
it was settled in writing in your file
do you understand that
yes I do the second thing you got to
understand is do not allow them to have
electronic access to your checking
account they're going to want to say
okay we'll take it but what's your
checking account number we'll take the
money out your checking account because
a lot of these debt buyers are crooks
and they will clean out your checking
account and let's say you had $4,000 in
there and you agree to to they'll take
the whole four out you know me so you
cannot let them to have access to that
the only way you can do it is you can
send that you can overnight mail them a
cashier's check or you could do a Visa
prepaid card that has a certain amount
on it just for that one transaction or
something like that but you cannot let
them in your main checking account
because they will clean you out and
you've got no recourse okay you can't
you can't because you owe them $8,000
according to the paperwork and then they
only got four so they'll keep coming
after you forever and you know your end
up hiring a lawyer cost you twenty five
thousand bucks and you there's no way
okay so in writing and no electronic
access to your checking account
pull the copy of your credit bureau
report and begin to work your way
through cleaning up your life so there
you go thanks for the call hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]